[MUSIC]
RETO MEIER: Good afternoon
everyone.
And welcome to this week's
episode of "The App Clinic."
This week we are looking
at sleep monitoring
and recording apps.
My regular colleague, Andy
Lewis, has been hard at work
testing these out.
And unfortunately, that means
he's currently sleeping.
So we're going to hopefully get
some of his input on some
of these apps a little later in
the program if he's able to
arouse himself from sleep and
give us some of his insight.
Now, that's just how important
we take our jobs here at "The
App Clinic." We're willing to
sleep during the day on a
Friday just so that we can
give these apps the
appropriate attention
that they deserve.
So we're going to look
at three apps today.
They are Sleep as
Android, Circle
Alarm, and Sleep Recorder.
And they all basically are
designed to do the same thing.
So they're designed to help you
get a good night's sleep.
Now, certainly, the first and
last of these two which we're
going to look at are designed
specifically as sort of your
own private sleep study.
You get the device.
You put it on your bed.
And it measures vibrations using
the sensors to see how
good a night's sleep you're
getting-- whether you're
twisting and turning, moving
around, or whether you're just
lying there in a
comatose bliss.
The middle app--
Circle Alarm-- is a little
bit different.
It's actually an alarm
clock, essentially.
Which we looked at these
little while back.
It was still the third highest
rated app in the
category this week.
So we are going to
take a look.
But it is a little bit different
from the other two.
We're going to spend a little
bit more time on those apps.
So--
getting started--
what do we really want from
these sorts of apps?
Well, what it really comes down
to is we're looking for
something which is really
easy to use.
It's always fun to have
moving things.
Now, it's says Device Profile
Wishlist at the top.
It's not.
It's actually the sleep
monitoring wishlist.
That's my lack of preparation
getting in the way there.
But really, what I want is
something which I can start up
and it doesn't take
a lot of effort.
Now, I think you can get a lot
of the requirements for an app
like this, which is basically
a tracking app.
In this instance, it's
tracking your sleep.
But a lot of the same learnings
and sort of
optimizations are going to be
very similar to what we looked
at a few weeks ago when we
were looking at fitness
tracking apps.
So like those apps-- like
Endomondo, RunKeeper, or
runtastic--
you want something that's
relatively easy to get going
which doesn't take a lot of
attention but then has rich
analytics once you've used it.
So that you're able to sort of
get started, record things
really easily, and then spend
your time analyzing the
results at your leisure.
So the first app that we're
going to take a look at today
is Sleep as Android.
And you can see here they've
got a feature graphic.
They have a feature graphic
here, which is
along the right lines.
It's a little noisy.
And what they've done here
is they've done sort
of a classic mistake.
And they've used the feature
graphic as a place to put all
of their screenshots.
Now, there is a place
for screenshots
on the landing page.
So you don't need to put them
into your feature graphic.
Now, the big reason for not
doing that is that when this
gets shrunk down into a tiny
size on a phone for one of our
smaller feature slots,
it's going to
become basically a mess.
You're not going to be able
to see these screenshots.
You're not going to be able to
make out any of this detail.
So it becomes messy and not
something which we're likely
to feature.
And similarly, if you're just
sort of browsing here, all of
the information that you've
got there on the feature
graphic-- the name,
the screenshots--
are all available elsewhere.
So I think you almost want to
focus just on what they've got
here and maybe try and
make that more
of the feature graphic.
You really want to give people
a vibe-- a feel for the app--
rather than trying to cram all
of your advertising material
all in one place.
Similarly, they've done
a reasonably good job
with their icon here.
It's distinctive.
It has a distinctive
silhouette.
It's, again, perhaps not
quite stylized enough.
It does tend to lose some of
its impact when you get the
smaller icon.
But it's definitely along
the right lines--
so definitely good work and
maybe a little bit more work
to be done here.
So moving on, once you get the
app going-- and I'm going to
do that on my phone as well--
but you can see here straight
away that they've got sort of
the right idea.
It's got a modern-looking UI.
It's kind of hollowish.
It's not quite hollow.
It's not quite an action bar.
And that's one of the things
which I really want to
highlight for these guys-- is
you can see in particular on
the pseudo action bar that
they've got along the bottom,
the alignment isn't
quite right.
So they've got the overflow
icon that looks right.
But it's not quite in
the right place.
And so you really want to think
about if you're going to
use some of the common UI
paradigms within the platform,
it's really important to use
them in a way that's
consistent with other apps using
the same controls-- the
same paradigms.
Where it really gets confusing
is if it's something that
looks kind of like something
that you're expecting but
doesn't quite work
in the same way.
It produces slightly different
results or is laid out
slightly differently.
That just causes confusion.
So you're almost better off
doing something completely
unique if you want to do any
sort of significant variance
on one of the existing
UI pieces.
Similarly, we've got the little
icon on the bottom
right, which is kind of cute.
But it actually just adds
visual clutter.
And you can actually see it says
"Home" there, which is
actually, I think, a description
of where you are
within the app.
Either way, it's kind
of confusing.
Because is it clickable?
Is it not?
Is it a navigation prompt?
Or is it just decoration?
You really want to try and keep
your screen as clean and
clear as possible.
Now, I'm not going to go into
too much detail on the UI
because that's kind of Android
design and actions territory.
And I don't want to step
on their toes too much.
But if we switch to
the giant phone--
if we're really lucky, the giant
phone will be working--
excellent--
so you can see, they've
got this
distinctive UI on the screen.
It's got this bright green--
almost sort of similar sort of
coloring to HTC Sense's UI from
at least a couple years
ago when I last looked at it.
You've got sort of the
pseudo action bar
here along the bottom.
And they've sort of put the time
in that as well, which
make sense.
But it's also kind of redundant
because I have the
time on the top of my phone
up here as well.
So it's kind of like
I'd rather see the
overflow menu here--
down along the bottom here where
it should be-- where it
kind of belongs on Android.
Otherwise, it just makes
it a bit confusing.
Otherwise, what we've got
here along the bottom is
effectively your tab.
So each of these--
and again, this is a little bit
confusing because we've
combined the concepts of an
action with the concepts of
navigation.
So things like hitting the moon
button effectively puts
you to sleep.
So that's an action--
fair enough.
But hitting the bar brings up
the activity for being able to
monitor your previous sleeps.
And so it's gets a little
bit confusing.
Because what's an action?
What's a navigation?
It should be a little easier,
particularly for users.
You want to make sure users know
what to expect whenever
they're pressing something
on your UI--
so making that a little
more predictable--
perhaps using something
similar to Android.
And in particular in this
layout, they've used something
that looks like in action bar,
but it almost feels like
they're trying to cheat.
So one of the big pieces of
feedback we often have is that
you're not supposed to have
tabs along the bottom.
And I'm sure the explanation
here is,
well, they're not tabs--
right?
It's an action bar.
You're allowed to have an action
bar along the bottom.
And it's true.
You are.
But only as sort of the second
half of a split action bar.
And we don't have anything
along the top here.
So I'd much rather like to see
this flipped around so that
the action bar sits
on the top.
You've got navigation
on the left.
You've got actions on the right.
and it's a lot clearer
as to exactly how it all
is supposed to work.
So here, again, we go through.
You hit plus.
It lets you set an alarm as to
when you want to wake up.
Or you can just have a
nap, which is nice.
So I'm not going to go into too
much detail on the UI in
the interest of time.
But kind of the key is here when
you press the Go button.
And it's going to start
recording my sleep.
And it's going to use a variety
of senses in order to
do that and give me an
indication of how good a
night's sleep I have,
which is nice.
That's basically the
whole purpose.
But what I think is kind of,
again, confusing here is that
we have an overflow icon, which
I'm covering slightly.
So you've got this overflow
icon and sort of
unpredictable behavior.
So if I click this, it's going
to bring up sort of this
contextual menu bar, which is
not really what I'm expecting.
It's kind of a dialogue where
I'm expecting a pop-up
overflow menu.
The things which we've
got here to set
are all fair enough.
It's just, again, the
way that it behaved.
And if we leave this screen long
enough, it'll all turn
off and go dark, which
again is nice.
So you can see here--
dimming screen--
touch-- or back to return.
And so this is good because
it means that the
phone can stay on.
And if it wants to use senses,
it's going to have to stay
active while I'm asleep.
So it's really important
here that it does
this, which is nice.
We hit Back and it automatically
records
everything, which is good.
So otherwise, it works well.
It does what it's
intended to do.
But I think really the key for
this app is all about tweaking
the UI-- making the navigation
and the actions a little bit
easier-- a little bit
more obvious.
Otherwise, great information
around statistics--
well displayed, as well.
I really like the use of graphs
and tables to try and
make this information as easily
consumed as possible.
Now, I didn't get a chance to
check to see if they have a
tablet app.
I'm hoping that they do.
Because again, this is a great
example where you're going to
use the phone to do the
actual recording.
But it'd be great to be able to
sit down on your couch-- at
your table--
with the tablet app and really
dig deep into the statistics
and the analysis on
a bigger screen.
So, hopefully, the developer's
watching.
And they can let us know.
Or possibly some of the other
viewers can let us
know just as easily.
Let's move on.
Let's have a look
at Circle Alarm.
So, Circle Alarm is kind
of a simpler concept.
This is basically just an alarm
clock which is going to
let you set alarms in as an
intuitive and simple and fast
method as possible.
And it's actually surprising--
or unsurprisingly enough--
quite similar to the redesign
of the Android Clock in the
latest Jelly Bean release.
Now, we can see here that
they've done a great job with
their feature graphic--
big--
bold--
gives you a stylized indication
of what the app is.
Their feature graphic mirrors
what they've got here for
their icon, which again, is
beautiful, distinctive
silhouette.
So straight away, the app looks
really nice when you
land on it on Google Play--
gives you that professional
feeling.
So they've done a really
good job there.
If we actually move on to the
app itself, you can see that
they've maintained that sort
of professional field
throughout.
They've got the hollow
styling.
Everything works the
way it should do.
And in fact, if we go
to the giant phone--
I'll pop it up-- you can see
that, again, it's this sort of
minimalist simplistic approach
to UI design.
We've got an action here.
If we hit plus, it adds a new
alarm, which then if we click
into it, you kind of get to the
key-- the magic part of
the app-- which is being able
to set an alarm just by
dragging these circles around.
Which these days, now that the
Google built-in clock works
along the same lines with
these sorts of circular
affordances to be able to set
time, it's something that's
quite familiar and
quite intuitive.
So I think they've done a
pretty good job here.
Again, I'm not going to go into
too much depth because
it's a fairly straightforward
app in terms of what it's
trying to do.
It doesn't have quite the same
depth as the other apps that
we're looking at.
But they've executed in
a really nice way.
They've put all of the
information front and center.
As soon as you sort of touch
anything, you get immediate
feedback as to what
it's doing.
When the alarm is set--
how often--
what ringtone you want to use
is all put in one place,
making it a really simple,
easy-to-get-started app.
And I think that's something
which the other two apps which
we're looking at today
can sort of take
something away from.
They have a much more
complicated set of
functionality.
But that doesn't mean that the
use has to be equally as
complicated.
In fact, the best apps offer a
lot of functionality but don't
make you feel like you have
to learn it first.
And that's one of the big pieces
of feedback we saw from
the community as well
as our own review
of Tasker last week--
fantastic app--
passionate users who
really, really love
what's going on there.
But the learning curve of trying
to figure out how to
use it is putting people off.
And I think that really
resonated with a lot of people
who watched the show last week
in Android Design and Action,
which looked at one
of the redesigns.
Really resonated-- this idea of
trying to make it simpler--
trying to make it easier.
And I think that's what
a lot of people want--
is these apps that they love to
use-- the services, which
they find hugely useful--
but they want to have it be easy
to use-- to be sort of
more of a magical experience
where you're not learning a
piece of software.
You're just taking advantage
of a service.
So I'm rushing through today's
show because I want to try to
keep it a little more succinct
than perhaps we sometimes do.
So let's have a look
at the next app.
So this Sleep Recorder.
And you can see here, no feature
graphic, which is a
real shame.
Without a feature graphic,
you can't be featured.
You don't have a chance of
being in the pure Android
collection, either.
And really, the biggest thing
here is that you're going to
be limiting your downloads.
So the lack of a feature graphic
on a landing page
actually has a significant
impact on the number of people
who are likely to download it.
And it's not only that,
but the quality
of the feature graphic.
So if getting lots of downloads
is something that's
important to you, it's important
to have that feature
graphic and for it to be good.
Now, this is an app
which spends a
lot of time on design.
They've used a skeuomorphic
design, which
you'll see in a moment.
So, clearly, look and feel is
something that's important.
So it's really an opportunity
here to take that same
attention to detail which you
have within your app and put
it here front and center,
which is basically your
advertising to the world--
your first point of
impression.
You know, we always
say that first
impressions are really important.
And that's exactly what you're
talking about on a landing
page in Google Play-- is
trying to make a first
impression which is going
to make people
want to use your app.
In terms of the icon,
you can see it's OK.
It's kind of the rounded, square
image, which we're
trying to move away from.
So, again, this may be an
opportunity to think about how
to make this into something
which is a little more
distinctive--
more of a silhouette rather than
sort of an image painted
on a rounded, square canvas.
If we look at the app itself,
you can see that they've gone
for a very skeuomorphic
design.
It looks a lot like a tape
recorder, basically, with sort
of a record, playback, and fast
forward affordances in
the middle.
You've got this analog
indication of your sleep
patterns, effectively.
So it looks kind of like an
EKG mixed with a tape
recorder-- sort of a lie
detector vibe, almost.
I guess that's what it puts
me in the mind of
when I look at it.
It kind of looks like a lie
detector for my sleep.
So you definitely feel
judged, which isn't
necessarily a bad thing.
So it is a recorder.
It looks like a recorder.
So it's definitely on the
right track there.
They have taken a skeuomorphic
design approach, which is
quite in contrast to the first
app that we looked at, which
was much more of a clean
hollow-based theme.
And, you know, really,
I'm not making a
judgment call on this.
I think that both are
valid options.
Really what I'm trying to judge
here is whether or not
their design choices are making
it easier for me as a
user to get started
and use that app.
And to be honest, with this app,
I struggled a little bit.
So if I switch to the
giant phone--
here we go.
Whoa, Sleep Recorder
has stopped.
So that's not a good sign.
I'm not going to record
it right now.
But I will hopefully be
able to go back and
record that for you.
So, again, Rate Us-- select
Sleep Recorder--
soliciting five star reviews
and ratings--
not great--
kind of obnoxious.
I understand that you
want people to rate
and review your app.
And there are certainly ways
to do that, But this is the
second or third time that
I've launched the app.
It feels like this is maybe
not the right time,
particularly because when I'm
going to be launching this the
first few times, it's likely to
be when I'm getting ready
for bed in order to
record my sleep.
I don't want to be interrupted
with anything which isn't sort
of key to that.
And so this is perhaps something
which you would
display later while you're sort
of viewing the analysis
rather than at the point in time
where you really don't
have any time to spare.
So I'm going to say No Thanks.
And you can see, everything's
moving around.
So we've got this beautiful
skeuomorphic design.
And we've got needles
bouncing around.
We've got rotary dials
which I can turn.
And what I like about it
is that it's simple.
There's no overflow button.
There's a very limited number
of things you can do.
And everything that I press
has an immediate reaction.
Now, where I'm a little bit less
thrilled is that it's not
obvious what any of the things
that I'm touching do.
So I can turn this.
And it's going to change
my Delay from 1 to 30.
But I don't know what
that Delay is for or
what the units are.
So I'm a little bit at a loss.
Like, I can change it.
But I don't know what it does.
And again, I can dial
this around.
And it changes the color
on the dial.
But I really don't know
what I'm doing.
So it's kind of a cool effect.
But in terms of feedback,
it's underplayed.
It's a little too simplistic.
It's perhaps relying on me
understanding what the analog
equivalence of this design are
in order to be able to
understand it.
So here I would try and make it
a little bit more obvious
to users who are going to open
it for the first time to
understand what are these
things doing-- how am I
supposed to use them?
So one thing which I
am familiar with
is the Record button.
So I hit Record because
that's what you do.
In fact, if I was going to take
my tape recorder analogy
to its maximum, I'd hit Record
and Play at the same time.
But in any case, I hit Record.
And it pops up with a modal
dialog-- of all things--
telling me that I'm
holding it wrong.
If I want to start, I
don't press Record.
I press the button in
the middle, which is
a little bit confusing.
Because, well, clearly
this is a tip.
Why not make it so that the
Record button is the way that
you start it?
And I'm sure that there
is a reason for it.
And in fact, what I have
determined is that I think
basically these buttons
along the bottom
are navigation tabs.
So hitting Record is how I
go into recording mode.
And hitting Play is how I go
into the Playback tab.
So it's basically tabs as
indicated by the depression of
the buttons.
So I go from Playback
to Record.
And then clearly, I'm
already in Record.
So if I hit Record again, that's
why I get the dialogue.
So the fact that there is a
dialogue tells me that enough
users are doing this that
perhaps this particular
paradigm isn't working
for you.
And that's, I think, one of the
risks when you're using
something skeuomorphic--
is that you really want
to be careful.
Because the Record button
means start recording.
That's how it works on the
analog device which you are
creating a design around.
So as soon as you create a
design that looks the same as
a real-world object but actually
the behavior is
different, then it gets
really confusing.
So that's something
you want to avoid.
And in this instance, I think
fundamentally hitting Record
should start the recording.
So maybe rework the way those
tabs have been implemented to
make it a little bit more
obvious, particularly because
the analogy between fast
forward and favorites--
I like the alliteration--
that's cool--
but it's not necessarily
obvious.
So it's a design which really
means that you have to click
everything on the screen before
you know what anything
on the screen does.
And so that's just increasing
that learning curve.
It means that before I can
decide whether or not I want
to use this particular app--
of which there are several
other apps
which do the same thing--
I need to learn the
whole thing first.
So something which works much
more like the fitness tracking
apps that we looked at a couple
of weeks ago-- like
Endomondo--
you start it up--
big button-- big Play
button right in the
middle of the screen.
I hit that.
And it starts recording.
I don't have to have learned
anything else.
I don't need to record
anything.
It's just going to start
doing exactly what I
expect it to do.
And then I can figure out how
the rest of it works further
down the track.
And so that's kind of the
approach that you want to take
for anything like this,
particularly these sleep apps
which are going to, like I said,
they're going to be used
when you're ready for bed.
You don't want to have to spend
a lot of time learning
how the app works right before
you use something like this to
monitor your sleep.
So if we go back to the
recording tab, and hit Record,
again, another modal dialog.
Modal dialogs are possibly going
to be one of the next
topics I look at
on Table Flip.
They drive me crazy.
Modal dialogs really don't
belong in any operating system
since somewhere in the
mid to early 90s.
If you want to display
information to users, there's
a bunch of ways that
you can do that.
And there's really very, very
few options-- so, very few
times-- when you need to pop
up something which blocks
their progress in the app.
It's really something which
should only be done by system
dialogs, essentially, to say,
hey, you can no longer
interact with anything else.
Because of this reason, I'm
going to display this alert.
So for this--
providing a tip-- it's a good
tip-- you definitely need to
make sure that your device is
connected to power before you
use it, but there's probably
better ways to present that
information than
a modal dialog.
So I hit OK, eventually.
And so now I can see that the
Delay was a countdown time in
seconds before it started
recording.
So I guess the idea there
is you hit Record.
And then you can put it next
to your bed or expect that
you're going to read for another
20 minutes or whatever
else, well, maybe you just know
that you fidget for the
first 15 minutes of sleep.
And you really don't
want to record
anything until after that.
So that's what that toggle is.
Now, what's not 100% clear now
is whether or not it's
actually started recording.
Now, from my experiments
earlier on, it wasn't.
I thought that at this point,
the countdown had finished.
It was recording.
But then there was nothing
in my history.
So I think--
no, I think it was recording.
But, see-- now the countdown
is like a minute.
So, again, the theme around this
app is basically this--
is that it's hard for
me to understand
what it's doing quickly.
And most users aren't going to
take the time to sit down and
really learn your app front
to back before they decide
whether or not they
want to use it.
They're going to have downloaded
this plus three or
four of your competitors.
And they're going to run through
them really quickly to
see which one looks the nicest
and provides the functionality
that they want.
So you really want to try and
reduce that learning curve as
much as you can.
So--
oh, it's saying again if
I want to switch tabs--
and it's telling me that I have
to stop the recording
before I can listen to other
recordings, which makes me
think that what this is actually
recording while I'm
sleeping is not movements so
much as actually the noise
while I'm in bed, which is
an interesting take.
So I guess we've got apps
which look at things a
different way-- one which is
using sensors to determine
your sleep and the other
which is using audio.
Or perhaps they're
both using audio.
I should probably have checked
that more closely.
And really, it doesn't
matter--
either way. whether you're
recording sort of movement or
whether you're recording
audio, it's the same
principles applied to
all of the apps.
It's just which sensor hardware
you happen to be
using in order to
record things.
And I think a great app would
actually use all of the
senses-- everything that you've
got on the device-- to
sense everything that
is changing
while you are sleeping.
So I think I can stop
the recording.
I can go back here.
And again, this is kind
of confusing.
Because there is no recording
even though I thought that I
had been recording.
And again, there's a couple
of UI tweaks here.
We've kind of got this iPhoney
style buttons navigation at
the top, which is, again,
a little bit
counter to what we expect.
And particularly here, it's a
little disconcerting because
you've got this pure
skeuomorphic design on the
bottom and then sort of an
iPhone design at the top.
Again, it's just a confusing
thing for users.
So I think as useful as the app
is, the biggest thing--
the best thing-- that they can
do here is kind of think about
how that onboarding--
that onramping is for users.
How are you going to get them
to really understand how to
use the app and see how
beautiful and simple it is
without having to spend a lot
of time learning the things
which are hidden?
So one of the things that you're
going to need to learn
if you want to build
an app like this--
certainly, the first app
is around sensors.
So, motion sensors is something
which we have a
developer guide for on
developer.android.com.
You're also going to want to
look at how to use the
microphone for apps like the
last app that we looked at to
be able to take in that
input and then do
the analysis on that.
So all of that information
is available on
developer.android.com.
For sensors--
in fact, for all sensors--
both mics and motion
and lights and
all kinds of things--
I think all of which would be
really useful to create a
great app like this.
[? Anchor ?]
Tim and Tony did a great
presentation on the
Sense-itive side of Android
at Google I/O last year.
So you should definitely
check that out.
And they've done some really
clever things with all the
different sensors to be able
to create really inventive
ways to monitor things--
things like--
I think Tony actually put
together a heart rate monitor
based on audio input.
So it's kind of crazy.
But these are the sorts of
things that you can use.
And I would really love to see
apps like these taking that to
the next step so that you're
recording everything--
turning all of the sensors on
for something like sleep
analysis to determine
am I moving?
Are there noises?
Are there light changes?
All of these things
are able to be
determined with your phone.
In fact, you can even record
changes in barometric pressure
on some of the newer devices.
So then you can create a really
rich idea of exactly
what is happening to your
environment while you're
sleeping and create a really
rich analysis for sort of your
at-home sleep recording
purposes.
So before we sign off, let's
have a quick look at our
prescriptions for each
of the apps.
And you'll see that there's a
lot of similarities in what
I'm asking for here.
So for the first app-- for
Sleep as Android--
think about a more standard
action bar, simpler
navigation, standardized
settings.
And just make the whole
thing easy to
understand and get started.
For Sleep Recorder, I think,
again, you kind of need a
little bit of a UI overhaul.
It doesn't need to be completely
redesigned.
I'm not saying that you
shouldn't be using a
skeuomorphic design.
I think that adds a
certain simplicity
that works quite well.
But I found it really hard to
understand how to get going.
And I think that's something
that could really benefit and
help increase your user
engagement, particularly
things around the
modal dialogs.
As soon as you find that you
need to tell your users that
they're doing something wrong,
that's usually a pretty clear
indication that perhaps you
haven't created it in a way
that they find intuitive.
And overall, just make the
whole thing easier to
understand.
In terms of the Circle Alarm,
I haven't given any specific
advice there.
I think you've done a
really great job.
It looks really nice-- provides
simple functionality
that works really well.
So, nice work on that.
So that is all for today--
the quick solo version of "The
App Clinic." Don't forget to
tune into Roman, Nick, and Adam
for Android Design in
Action on Tuesday.
Hopefully they'll be setting
their design skills loose on
some of the apps that we looked
at today after a really
popular session last week where
they looked at redesign
for Tasker.
Couple of announcements for the
Android developer Team.
We have embraced the new
communities on Google+.
So there is an Android
development and an Android
design community both available
from the Android
Developers + page on Google+.
These communities are
really for you guys.
We've created them as a place
that's kind of supposedly
semi-official.
You can create your own
communities and be part of
that, which is awesome.
In this community, we're going
to do some light moderation
just to try and keep the spam
down-- try and make sure that
it's a friendly environment for
everyone to be a part of.
But it's really your
community.
And it is whatever you
guys make of it.
So, participate.
Take part.
Let us know how you would
like to see it shaped.
And we'll see what we
can do to help move
things in that direction.
We also have a developer survey
currently ongoing at
bit.ly/androiddevsurvey.
So if you're an Android
Developer, designer, product
manager, distribution
engineer--
basically, if you have any
impact at all-- if you're in
any way associated with building
Android apps-- we
would love to hear from you--
get some of your feedback
on the things
that we've been doing--
some of the assumptions that we
have-- so that we can help
build better tools-- better
products-- for you guys to
have a successful Android
experience.
Now, next week there will
be no app Clinic.
We are all going off
to an offsite in
Carmel late on Friday.
So we are going to be preparing
for that rather than
preparing for the show.
We will be back with, I think,
at least one more episode
before Christmas for those of
you who haven't disappeared on
your own Christmas vacations.
And we're not 100% sure what
we're going to do.
So hit up the Trello board.
And basically vote for
the apps that you'd
like us to look at.
I think the two top trending
categories right now are, I
think, book readers and what
was the other one?
Dan?
I can't remember.
DAN: I think it was remote
control apps.
RETO MEIER: Remote control
apps-- that's right.
So book readers and remote
control-- they're the two top
categories at the moment.
We're going to go with whichever
one has sort of the
most votes for the top apps
in this category.
So if you have a strong opinion,
do you jump in there.
And if you have an app
in that category,
definitely go to Trello.
Self-nominate your app.
We love to do self-nominations
and then work with the
developers who we talk to on
the App Clinic to help you
guys build your app and
make it even better.
And the top ones we're going
to put into our own pure
Android collection.
Now, we have three nominees
for apps to
appear in pure Android.
We're going through the details
now-- making sure that
we're happy with them and hoping
to launch that, again,
before Christmas.
So we'll hopefully have
more information about
that for you soon.
So, until then, enjoy the
lead-up to the holiday period.
Happy building more apps.
And thank you very much
for watching.
I'm Reto Meier.
And this has been "The
App Clinic."